could we see co-op between link and
zelda in breathtak too
she did
[Music]
well it finally happened after two years
of silence from aonuma and his team we
finally got ourselves a new breath of
the wild 2 trailer and
everyone lost their mind not me though i
kept it cool
it's in the sky even though the trailer
itself was
only about one and a half minutes long
there's quite a lot of stuff to analyze
and speculate about and
ideas are already running rampant
instead of doing one big analysis of the
trailer in its entirety i've decided i'm
gonna do things a bit differently
first off you can bet your sweet pokemon
horn that everybody and their mother
will have a full analysis up before i'm
done thinking about what this tree in
the background means
i'm also still in the middle of moving
house so i gotta spread my efforts out a
little bit to keep my sanity so what
i'll be doing instead is i will upload
multiple shorter videos covering the new
sql trailer where we focus on one
specific thing at a time
this way i can go more in depth and keep
the runtime at a manageable length until
i'm ready for the bigger projects again
today we will be looking at some of the
new architectures seen in the
presentation which
there is quite a lot of actually we'll
talk about the overall aesthetics its
connection to other tribes that may or
may not start with a z as well as where
they could have come from since none of
the structures seen here were present on
the surface in breath of the wild
so let's dive right in
to start off let's list all the new
architecture chronologically as seen in
the trailer
the first one i was able to spot was the
shot where the sky is first introduced
and i'm not talking about the island
link seems to be aiming for we do see
some road-like structure on the surface
of the island but given the distance
it's hard to say if these are new
there were definitely paved roads in
specific sections of breath the wild's
map as well but as the camera pans
upwards closer to link we can see what
seems to be a large floating building in
the distance
because of the clouds we can only see
the very top of it however in the very
next shot we see a similar looking
structure on the top right of the frame
which is possibly the very same building
from a different vantage point we can
also see some additional smaller
constructions on the islands right here
these in turn look like they might be of
the same type as the one from the next
shot
which is in my opinion the most
beautiful looking one in the entire
trailer we can see two things
some man-made walls and some sort of
archway which kind of reminds me of a
japanese torii gate the next scene is
where we get a first more detailed look
at one of the new buildings but we'll go
over the actual details later
next we have the shot of link flying
past a bunch of pokoblins riding a stone
talus which is amazing
by the way in the first few frames
however we can see some small details on
the left of the frame
now this building right here looks like
the ruins we are familiar with
in fact i'm pretty sure this is long
long range since we can also see a small
section of castle town right here but
these two pieces of debris right here
don't look familiar at all the shape
clearly shows that it is man-made but
these were definitely not in breath of
the wild they seem to originate from the
same type of walls we saw in the sky
which leads me to believe that these
might be pieces that have broken off
when the islands rose to the sky
and then landed in hyrule field next we
have the close-up of the green hand and
although it doesn't show an
actual building we do see that link is
laying on a piece of floor with a
circular shape to it and is decorated
with an unknown scripture
again more details later in the part
where link uses his new
stasis time manipulation thingy we can
see some new types of enemy camps they
definitely don't look like any of the
camps we saw in breath of the wild
also moblins wear hats now so that's
pretty neat
i would say then we come to the first
indication that despite all the sky
footage there are some underground
sections as well
who knows this might even be a dungeon
here's hoping this cave-like area also
has man-made features
walls and pillars and some sort of altar
which i'm guessing might spawn a chest
once the enemy is defeated
then we have what is probably the most
detailed view of one of the new types of
architecture in the game
we can see floor tiles a sort of pillar
with a pine cone shape on it and a stone
stairway leading to a platform with a
roof on it i'm also
guessing that this might be the same or
at least a similar area as the shot with
the new robot enemy here too you can see
the stairs a similar looking building
as well as the pinecone thing in the
background we can also spot some similar
stone buildings on some of the other
islands in the distance
and those are all the shots featuring
new architecture there might be even
more in the final shot of the castle
rising but with the lighting and the
distance it's hard to see the finer
details and thus it's hard to say if
they are existing ruins or not
so that sums up all the new buildings
now let's go over some of the finer
details
the first thing to mention is that it's
safe to say that with the exception of
the new enemy camps they seem to have
been made by the same people as they all
have similar features
they all have similar looking pillars
which start out thin at the bottom and
get wider at the top
even the walls inside the cave-like area
have this trait they are also all made
from the same grayish looking stonework
some of the stonework also has some sort
of writing on it which doesn't match
with any of the established alphabets
from previous games
which brings us to the symbols seen in
the close-up of the green hand
at first i thought they were gerudo
scripture but when you pull up the
gerudo alphabet they are definitely not
the same
the only one that kinda looks like a
gerudo symbol is this one right here
which bears some resemblance to the a
or e but even this is not a complete
match whatever this language is it
probably has something to do with the
tribe that built these structures
furthermore a lot of the small buildings
we see on the various floating islands
have the same open design that is to say
a floor with pillars and a roof but no
walls
in the shot where we see one of them up
close we can also see some sort of stone
altar perhaps these will serve as this
game's variant of fast travel points
seeing as there's no trace of any of the
sheikah shrines or towers anywhere in
hyrule's landscape this could mean that
once you visit an island you can easily
travel back there in the future
the only building that sticks out from
the rest is the big one in the first two
shots we covered it still seems to have
the same grey stonework but it's much
bigger and does seem to have closed
walls
at the same time it also has the same
feature where it gets wider at the top
i'm really hoping that this might be one
of the game's dungeons who knows maybe
the shot inside that enclosed space
where link is using his new flamethrower
ability might be
inside this building now the big
questions remain who built these
structures and how did they get here
i mean they certainly weren't there in
breath the wild obviously
the zonai would be a prime candidate
once again but there is however
one issue as elusive as the zone i are
their architecture is the one thing we
do know
quite a lot about and none of the
buildings seen in the new trailer are
unmistakably of
zonai origin yes they do have some
similar features
such as the swarvey tf-like decorations
and blocky design best seen on the
sargon bridge but it's just
different enough that we can say with
certainty that these are
zone i made there's no trace of the
recognizable spiral the snake engravings
or other ornaments on some of the walls
and statues now it could be that they
decided to
alter zonai architecture for this game
plus we've only seen a few buildings in
ruins so far
maybe there are more out there that do
feature the zonai characteristics we are
familiar with
i am quite certain that this is not
ancient hylian the ruins we find of them
are much more in line with roman
building styles such as round pillars
and smooth archways this new building
style is way too blocky compared to that
and as opposed to zonai architecture
which does have some resemblances
there are no features that match with
ancient hylian i will do a more in-depth
video
about the zonai connections in a later
video as there are definitely some
besides the architecture
finally we have the question of how in
the heck did these buildings suddenly
appear in the first place
like i said they were definitely not
there in breath of the wild i don't have
any definitive answers
obviously but there are two options that
came to my mind and could explain it
best
the first and most talked about option
right now is that the parts where we see
link traversing the skies takes place in
the past
far far in the past as a matter of fact
say these buildings
are indeed of zonai origin we could be
looking at an ancient version of hyrule
which of course would mean that time
travel is back
once again and this is definitely a
possibility in fact there are quite a
few time related hints all throughout
the trailer we see time manipulation
ability specifically a theme of
reversing time
then there's the fact that link is
wearing some very old school looking
clothing in some of the shots
they kind of remind me of roman or
ancient greek with the toga that only
covers one shoulder and the open
sandals in every shot where link is in
the sky he is wearing that same green
attire on his upper body whereas on the
surface he has always seen donning the
tunic we recognize from the first
trailer
in general hyrule looks different some
like mass nintendo bandit have already
pointed out some missing buildings that
were there in the previous game but are
gone now
indicating that this might take place in
an era before these were built
so yeah this could very well be taking
place far in the past but there is a
second option
and that is that the floating islands we
see are not pieces of hyrule's surface
from breath of the wild but instead new
landmasses that have perhaps
always existed far above the clouds just
because we see
hyrule castle rising doesn't
automatically mean that the rest of
hyrule will do so as well
yes i did suggest this in my video last
week but that was just a suggestion that
doesn't mean it's true
in fact even after hours of scrutinizing
the trailer i have yet to see
anything on the floating islands that i
recognize as something i know from the
surface
we also don't see any craters on the
surface from above
at least not right now anyway and even
in terms of the castle
who's to say it will rise up as high as
the clouds in the final shot it seems to
have stopped moving and it's just
floating there maybe this is the extent
of it it will just stay there like this
surrounded by malice a bit like ganon's
castle from ocarina of time
and that about covers the architecture
for now i hope to see you in the next
episode where i will go more in depth on
other aspects of the new trailer
the next part will be released very soon
and if you have your own ideas and
findings don't shy away from sharing
them down in the comments i might even
use them in a future episode
a big big thanks to everyone for the
amazing e3 live stream to my friends
charlie and mike for being there with me
and the amazing presents i got from you
guys
and lastly thank you to my ever so
gracious patreons and members and to
arno danboof
fume kage tokoyami andrei lechchilin
michael egger and an additional shout
out to shigeyako for upgrading their
pledge you are all
amazing as always and that is
all for now this is don signing off and
it's in the sky
[Music]
you